こんちわっす はじめしゃちょーです
アマゾンってほんとに不思議なものがたくさん売ってるんですよ。
アマゾンてほんとにいろんな商品にあふれてる。
良いものもあるし、悪いものもある。
今回もその謎を一つ、解いてあげようと思います。
はい今回買ったのはこちらです
ブアシャブアアアアアアブアアアブビャシャッバン
スウッハアア
商品はどこにいったっっ
はいこちらです
ドッキリ三ツ矢サイダー！！
まあ見た感じ完全に
三ツ矢サイダーですね。
は！？待ってこれ
超ルール書いてあんじゃん！
はぁぁぁぁぁ？？？
はあ”あ”あ”あ”あ”？？？？？？
えぇ、なんかアマゾンで見たとき
何にも書いてなかったんですよ
『ドッキリ三ツ矢サイダー』しか
書いてなくて
説明欄とか全然なくて
何か全然わかんなかった
んですけど、いま
見たらめっちゃ書いてあるんスよ
運が悪いと
缶がぶるぶる暴れだすって
はっきり書いてあります！！
そういうやつかい！！
えぇ、もっとなんか爆発するのかと
思ったら全然爆発しない
じゃないですかぁ！
えぇぇ～
ドッキリどころかもう
ドッキリどころかもう(２回目)
こんなの
ドッキリじゃないじゃないですかあ”あ”！！！！
とりあえず、
あけてみます。
バリバリバリビリリンチョｗｗｗ
おぉ。
おぉ、
見た目はすごい
似てると思うじゃないですか！！！！
も、あけ口が雑すぎて
これちょっとばれちゃうんじゃないですかぁ？？
でなんかここのタブを引いて
順番に引いてって
運が悪いとぶるぶる暴れだすらしいです。
やってみましょう。
100しょうもないや～ん
ガヂヂヂ
おｋ
『プシュ』ってなるこれを
やればたぶん
なんか
ガッッチャンｗｗｗ
ガッチャンｗｗｗ
運が悪いと
ガチャンｗｗ
ガチャンｗｗｗｗ
えぇこわい
ガッチャンｗｗ
ガチャ
うわっ！！
ぶるｗぶるｗｗぶるｗぶるｗｗぶるｗｗｗｗｗｗ
ガチャン…
あぁ！
結構怖いなぁ！
ガチャ
ぶるｗぶるｗｗぶるｗぶるｗｗぶるｗｗｗｗｗｗ
TU☆KA☆I☆ZU☆RA☆I
めちゃくちゃ振動してびっくりするとは思うんですけどもぉ
純粋に
ドッキリアイテムとしては
非常に使いづらい気がします。
え、これほんとにさあだってさあ
たぶんねぇわかんないけど
１２回くらいでなるんですよ
5、6
7、8
あれ？？８回じゃん
うまいこと仕掛けられれば
……ができると思うんで
ちょっとうまいことやってみます。
では！！
おし(小声)
じゃあ早速やってみます。
たくみぃぃぃぃぃぃぃぃぃ！！！！！！！
(え！？)
差し入れのジュースかったよぉ
（うお！？！！？)
あーのどかわいたなー(棒)
(うわ！絶対ドッキリやんけこれぇ)
（見るからに三ツ矢サイダーの缶ちゃうやんけぇ！）
（さすがのワイでもわかるわ！！）
（あかん）
（ さすがにばれ↑たでぇ、これはぁ）
（見るからに蓋おかしいやんけ）
（ど↑う↓見ても三ツ矢サイダーちゃうわ！！）
（な↑ん↓やねん）
（この蓋）
（なんなんねやこの蓋は！）
（まるで）
（三ツ矢…ダサいヤーや、ほんま）
（まあ大丈夫やろ）
（ポン↑コツ→やからな）
（たぶん引っかかるでぇ）
（カ↑メラまであるやんけえぇ）
（完→全↑にドッキリやわ！）
（まあええわ！）
（今回はワイのリアクション芸）
（見せ↑た↑るでぇ！）
ガチャ
ぶるｗぶるｗｗぶるｗぶるｗｗぶるｗｗｗｗｗｗ
どんがらがっしゃ――んｗｗｗ
ぶるｗぶるｗｗぶるｗぶるｗｗぶるｗｗｗ………
…
字幕作成者から一言
（へんな関西弁下手スギィ！）